poursuivons maintenant notre dossier sur
la qualité de l'eau potable au Québec
alors je vous rappelle plus de 300
villes québécoises qui présentent des
traces de polluants qu'on appelle des
polluants éternels c'est potentiellement
cancérigène est-ce qu'on doit
s'inquiéter on avait beaucoup de
questions pour la santé publique dans
notre entrevue précédente avec entre
autres le maire de Saint-Donat dans
l'eau et contaminée justement mais le
directeur de santé publique Luc Boileau
est avec nous bonjour Docteur Boileau on
est très content de vous avoir avec nous
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce dossier
là ce que ça vous préoccupe vous la
présence de ce produit qui s'appelle
pfas dans l'eau du Québec en fait c'est
un dossier qui nous intéresse beaucoup
de là à dire que nous sommes inquiétés
ou préoccupés non nous sommes toutefois
très intéressés très intéressé par le
dossier et beaucoup beaucoup de
d'informations qui émergent un peu
partout sur ce vos vos personnes juste
avant monsieur sauvé le mentionné donc
on est toujours intéressé ces questions
là parce qu'effectivement on a documenté
que chez certains de ces produits il y
en a des milliers il y avait des effets
qui pouvaient délétères dont on parlait
d'effets sur le système
dans le dossier des pfas la qualité de
l'eau potable et menacée avec les taux
qu'on a trouvé dans cette étude on dit
vraiment qu'il y a pas de situation
actuellement au Québec il y en avait une
à Val d'Or ou c'était plus élevé vous
l'avez mentionné tantôt
ils ont changé depuis
d'approvisionnement c'est un puits
d'approvisionnement très particulier à
utiliser de façon irrégulière ici à
Saint-Donat les gens peuvent dire mais
aux yeux on est à 77 82 c'est pas des
taux très très élevés actuellement selon
les règles du Canada c'est bien en deçà
des limites canadiennes on parle d'une
progression qui est pas encore établie
vers un 30 nanogramme total donc il
serait au dessus mais c'est pas un
énorme cela de tantôt on parlait de
norme c'est pas du tout un homme c'est
un objectif à atteindre graduellement
parce qu'il y a pas d'effets à 35 puis à
là-dessus en disant voici le seuil là à
partir duquel ça commencerait non vous
me dites non c'est pas c'est c'est pas
un seuil c'est c'est très différent
parce que c'est un dossier sur lequel
justement il n'y a pas de nom en fait
c'est un principe de précaution c'est
bien compris c'est un principe de
précaution que nous établissons ici au
Québec comme au Canada bien sûr c'est le
Canada qui établi ces éléments-là puis
tantôt on vous a mentionné que d'autres
États en Suède ce 90 ailleurs c'est ça
etc donc c'est c'est plus élevé aux
États-Unis
4 c'est vraiment spécifique à DPF qu'on
ne produit pas qu'on ne fabrique pas ici
au Canada ni au Québec qu'on peut
retrouver ça a été dit parce qu'il se
distribue dans l'environnement mais on
n'est pas dans des dispositions comme ça
que sur lequel travaille actuellement ce
n'est pas une énorme mais c'est bon
c'est quoi c'est un objectif qu'on veut
atteindre graduellement à travers le
Canada puis c'est ce qui est proposé
c'est pas encore établi et ici au Québec
aussi alors il y a moyen de travailler
avec les municipalités pour tendre vers
cela et c'est la même chose pour saint
Monsieur le Maire le disait tantôt il
regarde de différentes sources
d'approvision il va chercher son eau
dans la carchambault probablement qu'on
va attendre monsieur Boileau parce qu'il
dit moi j'ai besoin d'un encadrement
j'ai besoin de réponse la santé publique
parce que c'est pas Santé Canada si vous
sentez publique qui gère ça je vous les
donne mais je lui ai donné dans les
quelques instants puis vendredi dernier
donc c'est pas très longtemps on a eu
une rencontre avec la plupart des
municipalités qui voulaient venir nous
entendre on a mis ça très clair on n'est
pas du tout dans une situation à
l'hermiste on est dans une situation où
est-ce qu'on recommande toujours de
boire l'eau parce qu'elle est potable
puis elle est bonne pour la santé l'eau
c'est on se fait longtemps qu'on dit que
c'est le produit qui est le meilleur
allié chercher particulièrement au
Québec alors c'est une situation qui
n'est pas une source d'inquiétude mais
c'est une source évidemment d'intérêt
pour nous et de préoccupation qui sont
juste à avoir non pas dans l'immédiat
mais pour s'assurer que de la
progression de ce dossier là nous ne
nous perdra pas avec des beaux trophées
c'est un chercheur il est c'est un
expert dans ces questions là et il nous
dit on est devant beaucoup d'inconnus
donc manquer un intérêt à réaliser la
recherche commence là-dedans même même
la source de contamination de la source
d'eau potable de Saint-Donat on n'est
pas sûr c'est peut-être le site
d'enfouissement peut-être pas en fait on
voit qu'il y a beaucoup d'incertitude de
la part du maire aussi pour répondre à
ces questions-là donc il faut qu'elle
avance cette recherche vous avez besoin
d'avoir ces données là pour être capable
de continuer à certifier que l'eau est
bonne au Québec tout à fait et nous
avons une excellente collaboration avec
le ministère de l'Environnement qui nous
fournit toutes ces données là les
chercheurs comme Monsieur sauvé en
fournissent plusieurs autres c'est très
riche l'information qu'il nous donne
maintenant c'est à nous comme expert en
santé publique médecin et autres à
établir s'il y a un risque pour
l'instant en ce moment là et je vais
vous dire ça un bon moment les gens
peuvent continuer à consommer l'eau il y
a pas de souci à voir autour de ça s'il
y a des inquiétudes ils peuvent nous les
manifester on s'en occupe on étudie ça à
fond pour être certain qu'on chemine
tous dans le bon sens pour réduire
l'exposition EPFs parce que c'est pas
l'eau qui nous donne ça au maximum c'est
pas mal l'alimentation donc on est en
train de bien documenter ça pour avoir
des meilleures pratiques ici au Québec
pour la protection de notre population
et c'est notre job puis on l'a fait mais
soyez assurés que pour nous actuellement
il n'y a pas d'inquiétude à consommer
l'eau vous avez dit pour les gens qui
ont des soucis vous pouvez nous
contacter alors vous la sentez publique
ou les érections santé publique
régionale je sais qu'il y a des gens qui
sont inquiets entre dans la région
Saint-Donat c'est des gens qui ont des
puits alors ils sont pas connectés avec
le vaste réseau de Saint-Donat mais ils
attention est-ce que mon puits est
contaminé comment il peut faire pour le
savoir est-ce qu'il y a est-ce que c'est
à leur frais c'est à eux entreprendre
des démarches pour faire évoluer l'euro
ce sont des dispositions qui peuvent
être prises avec la complicité de la
municipalité ou de la Direction de santé
publique ou du ministère de
l'Environnement je vais pas rentrer dans
les détails mais chose certaine c'est
qu'il nous serait très étonnant que des
situations d'approvisionnement en eau
soit terrifiante sur le plan des pfas
quand on regarde au Québec en général on
a une situation très avantageuse par
rapport à ce qu'on voit aux États-Unis
on est tous compare très bien au reste
du Canada puis par rapport à ce qu'on
voit en Europe aussi où ils ont beaucoup
utilisé ça ils ont des usines de
fabrication de nous on est exemples donc
ça nous donne un avantage mais ça
circule ça s'en va partout on le
retrouve au numérique là on a des gens
qui consomment des poissons qui en a
plus que qu'ailleurs alors c'est un
sujet d'intérêt vraiment sérieux pour
nous nous y travaillons mais pour
l'instant il y a aucun signal envoyer à
la population de dire une consommait pas
l'eau dans nos municipalités elle est de
bonne qualité et Saint-Donat vous avez
entendu le maire est préoccupé pour la
santé de ses concitoyens il dit ça très
justement et très clairement nous nous
sommes convaincus que nous pouvons lui
donner toute l'information pour qu'il a
leur juste et qu'on ne dise pas aux gens
ben s'il vous plaît consommer pas
une situation pour le manganèse aussi on
a déjà un avis santé publique de ce
côté-là donc c'est une situation qui est
déjà
très importante pour à nos yeux et aux
yeux de la directrice de la santé
publique l'auteur Thibault à qui je
parlais justement plutôt aujourd'hui
alors c'est une situation sur le
manganèse mais pour pour vraiment
l'autre consommation il est pfas nous
sommes intéressés au dossier nous y
travaillons nous avons d'excellents de
collaborations des experts des
nationales de santé publique du
ministère de l'Environnement donc on a
vraiment beaucoup d'informations et des
chercheurs
à partager avec nous ou un message à
part un message de quel jeu un peu
finalement si on peut faire ça tant
mieux mais c'est aux gens à disposer si
nous font confiance mais je pense que
dans ces domaines là on a on a tout ce
qu'il faut pour redonner leur juste
la réaction ce soir merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI